okay I hate that we have to do this but
the amount of disinformation and lies
about the virus coming from our own
president is spreading virally so it's
not just the virus that's spreading
virally the lies are spreading virally
as well we are going to go on a tour now
not of the lies that Donald Trump is
told during his presidency that numbers
about 16,000 it would take us months to
go through them we were going to go on a
tour of lies not from the entire
coronavirus crisis because that would
take weeks we're just doing a partial
tour of the lies that Donald Trump has
told and spread just during the last few
days about coronavirus look at the havoc
that this man is wreaking first Donald
Trump insisted that he did everything
right away and correctly when it comes
to the defense production Act this is a
mechanism that harkens back to 1950 in
the Korean War
i misstated yesterday that this was a
world war ii era thing it's a Korean War
era thing from 1950 the idea is that in
a time of a national emergency war
pandemic whatever the government can
essentially force industry to produce
things that are needed for the war or
the pandemic Trump invoked the act
supposedly but didn't enforce it or use
it saying it's a tool that's ready if I
need it but I don't actually need it now
we need ventilators we need masks
urgently this has been a completely
incoherent explanation from Donald Trump
and the New York Times appears to have
figured out the conundrum Trump has been
lobbied successfully by the United
States Chamber of Commerce not to
actually use the defense production Act
because they don't like it so Trump has
been twisting himself into a pretzel the
last two or three briefings to say this
incoherent thing of well I invoked it
but I haven't used it it's ready and I'm
doing everything right and it's a lie
and it appears to be because industry
successfully lobbied him not to use it
number two Trump continues to hype
chloroquine and as if throw Meissen as a
possible game-changer something he
thinks will be the cure for coronavirus
we've already gone over this in detail
it's not a game-changer it's a possible
thing side-effects are a big issue
reports of heart and vision issues are
starting to come in and once again the
Surgeon General had to go on Fox News
where trumps this information spreads
quickly and say no the this and we're
gonna look at this this is right after
Fox and Friends had dr. oz on spreading
more of it here is Surgeon General
Jerome Adams explaining that this is not
a cure this is not what Trump is
claiming this this to be you know doctor
we had dr. oz on at the top of this hour
and what he talked about was how
promising he thinks that malaria drug
when used in concert with z-pak was with
one of the French doctors who treated 36
people and their viral level all went
from a hundred down to zero after just
five or six days he said his biggest
problem right now and he's starting his
own clinical trials at Columbia and he
mentioned the Cleveland Clinic I think
is gonna do the same thing he wonders
you know and worries about the fact that
we don't have enough pills yet in this
country if that works well here's the
thing about those drugs there's may and
there's and there's actually does and so
these may be promising and so we're
trying to make them as available as
possible to people across the country we
need to verify through studies that they
actually work but I also again want to
go back to the fact that we are it's not
practical to think we're going to treat
our way out of this problem with new
drugs or with ventilators or with
supplies we need to lower demand we need
more people talking about staying at
home it's why I reached out to Kylie
Jenner last week it's why my kids say
dad reach out to Lauren gray and Roman
Atwood and have them help these
Millennials understand they're spreading
virus and the more they spread the more
we're going to need these drugs the more
we're gonna need ventilators and masks
so there's an actual doctor trying to
push back against Trump's hyperbole and
distortion because he is being deceptive
he is spreading disinformation and it
already led to one death I'll tell you
about that later
continuing our true our tour of Donald
Trump's korone
virus lies of just the last few days
Trump is starting to tweet he did it
Sunday night he did it Monday night he
did it this morning he's starting to
tweet that maybe we're gonna wrap up the
social distancing the physical
distancing this is very dangerous and
meanwhile state governors who are
dealing with this in a more real way are
putting in place shelter and place
orders we just got one yesterday here in
Massachusetts and other states are
getting them as well but meanwhile
Donald Trump is spreading flat-out
dangerous speculation by tweeting Sunday
night that quote we cannot let the Cure
be worse than the problem itself at the
end of the 15 day period we will make a
decision as to which way we want to go
Trump again tweeting this morning we are
going to get people back to work but
we're gonna take care of older folks
Trump's economic adviser Larry Kudlow
also starting to parrot this saying we
don't want the cure to be worse than the
disease and this is extremely dangerous
number one there's no way in hell that
all we need is another seven days number
two you have people who are desperate to
start going out and do whatever they
want which I can understand I mean I
want to do it also but we can't give
people any cover under which to do it
and Trump is lying here and he shouldn't
be saying this and then lastly one of
the reasons Trump claims that he doesn't
need to enforce the defense production
Act is that GM and Ford are already
making ventilators and everything's
great this is just a lie
no automaker is anywhere near ready to
make ventilators GM General Motors
reportedly says they have a plan for
starting to obtain most but not all of
the parts they would need to be able to
begin the manufacturer of ventilators at
some point in the future it will
realistically take months for them to
even actually start churning out
ventilators they also don't need Trump's
permission to do it which Trump has been
saying with my permission GM is doing
this it is lie after lie after lie and
it's going to get much much more
one of the things about Donald Trump is
that the more difficult things get the
more likely he is to lie uncontrollably
and this is getting more and more
difficult the death toll is climbing
here in the US you should expect the
lies to continue my hope is that our
state governors can help fight this
because Trump's causing problems the
state governors that are taking this
seriously
Cuomo Newsom Baker others I know I'm
missing a lot of people he doesn't
understand anything about medicine or
the virus and the governors are having
to basically work against Trump in favor
of sanity and reason people around Trump
keep explaining this stuff yesterday
during the press conference Trump
started asking dr. Burks questions that
made it clear he barely knows anything
about a symptomatic contagion or any of
this stuff he doesn't get pandemics he
doesn't understand reality and there are
this is a very bad time for this degree
of weaponized ignorant incompetence and
delusions of grandeur and we may very
quickly get into this battle between
Trump saying get back to work and
governors and probably Airlines and
others saying no no we're not we're not
doing it and that may happen sooner than
later I'd love it if you checked out a
YouTube channel we're partnering with
their content is great and they're good
friends of the David Pakman show the
channel is called up flip and you can
get there at david pakman.com slash up
flip make sure you subscribe when you're
there if you own your own business if
you're thinking of starting one if
you're interested in entrepreneurship
and building companies as many of you
know I am I think you will love this
because every week up flip gives you
sort of an inside look at a successful
small business how did the entrepreneur
do it how was it built from the ground
up the stories are inspiring I always
love learning about how business owners
got to where they are and they share a
ton of wisdom about mistakes what they
learned really great insights and up
flip up loads new videos every Wednesday
featuring a totally new business check
it out at david pakman.com slash up flip
link is right down below underneath this
video subscribe to their channel and
click that Bell icon to get
notifications